when khabib fought Connor who are you
guys rooting for Connor I never really
I've never rooted against him but I
actually mean
Connor did much better than I expected
dude in fact people were talking about
Patty fighting grappling today I'm like
bro
it took four rounds for one of the best
Grapplers in the world in MMA to get
Conor and finish him I mean yeah he took
him down and couldn't do much with him
you know what I mean like in fact in the
third round you can see I think could be
kind of panic a little bit you know what
I mean like I was sitting there I could
sit and go whoa you know because you
know Connor's take down defense and even
when he got taken down his ability to
control wrist and frame walk to the cage
yeah he did a lot of good stuff more
success against khabib than anybody
right and I think khabib actually like
he stopped khabib's ground and pound
better than anybody okay you know I'm
sitting there going wow guys because he
was always winning them all you're right
but he's not winning how he thinks he's
not dominant and there's doubt going in
his mind right now